[Music]
uh manny's going to be talking about
how propaganda is subverting your
reality it's time for the truth
according to smooth manny
smith manny what is it you're going to
be talking about so everybody knows that
you're slightly being brainwashed like
everybody knows come on that's one of
the first things that i've agreed with
as the premise yeah yeah that's true oh
no i don't i disagree shut up you're
wrong dumb so gerald is wrong and
everybody is being brainwashed and they
know it right but
because the people like gerald they
think that brainwashing is like ciamk
ultra and it's like well that's because
you've said that well that that is part
of it yeah but that's not all of it the
main thing is the subtle
the subtle propaganda that is slowly
taking over your reality in order to
understand how this propaganda works we
need to understand what what is
propaganda like oh right right yeah we
need to our main character is the guy
who literally created not propaganda but
who weaponized propaganda outside of a
war element okay and that is edward
bernay so this is like a little edward
on my stake yeah and i love this quote
propaganda's executive arm of the
invisible government how could a person
create this uh this new propaganda but
weaponized it not in a time of war he's
a sigmund freud's nephew
oh
and he
weaponized freud's studies and he's like
oh we could totally use
people's desires subconscious desires
and just uh teach them how to want
things that they don't need
and
use that to manipulate see that would
make me think that they were less
effective because he's like let's use
people's desires like oh what are you
thinking like uh lust you're thinking
greed everyone wants to have sex with
their mothers it's so weird every day so
what we're gonna do is tempt people with
their own mothers it sounds ridiculous
but that is actually what he did so one
of his first clients was uh cigarette
companies yeah and they wanted women to
be able to smoke so they could have
fifty percent like philippines
and they're like okay so but at the time
women couldn't smoke it wasn't socially
acceptable for women to smoke so i do
know that because i do know that uh they
would they would say not stinky like
cigars because at one point cigars were
more popular and they were saying
cigarettes are less but now actually if
you ask most people they'll prefer the
smell of cigars than a cigarette it's
just that it's much it's heavier so
lighter so i do know those commercials
but do you know how he did it or why he
did it sleeping with his mother almost
women want their own penises and
cigarettes are the women's uh like sign
of having a penis that's how he thought
about that
but i have a clip there gary calls uh
cigarettes and uh it sounds ridiculous
but he he literally changed the social
norm of women being able to smoke in
public and he believed it's because they
wanted penises that's what he did okay i
mean it worked it worked that cigarettes
were a symbol of the penis every year
new york held an easter day parade he
persuaded a group of rich debutants to
hide cigarettes they were to light up
the cigarettes dramatically that's kimmy
schmidt bernays then informed the press
that he had heard that a group of
suffragettes were preparing to protest
by lighting up what they called torches
of freedom
he knew this would be an outcry and he
knew that all of the photographers would
be there to capture this moment the next
day this was not just in all of the new
york papers it was across the united
states and around the world and from
that point forward uh the sale of
cigarettes to women began
something with a single symbolic act
okay um
for possibly the first time since you've
been sitting in that chair you have my
attention
so what's crazy is that it wasn't just a
ridiculous thought it was that he he
teamed up with the press he didn't tell
them but he set up an event he set up a
protest filmed the pro it was basically
he invented the flash mob but he did it
to create a social
moment and then he coined the term for
it and he branded it that's that that is
branding freedom he invented advertising
um that's what he did but
do you guys think america is a
consumer's culture very much sure yeah
uh why
uh everybody's kind of looks at your
branding i mean every brands are
important people wear giant brands just
they scare us into buying stuff manny
yeah bro
bernice mother invented that
whoa
he literally created consumerism yeah uh
the all-american breakfast being what's
the all-american breakfast sausage eggs
hash browns
edward bernice the main purpose of it
was he wanted people to be so busy with
what they were consuming and feeling
good that they would be distracted
because that way society could be really
managed by the the people in power okay
um
and sure exactly the
the people that don't have um
accountability yes so here is democrats
i yeah i hijacked your show and this is
a clip called consumerism
1939 edward bernays created a vision of
a future world in which the consumer was
king it was at the world's fair in new
york top flight documentary and bernays
called it democracy and company after
company presented itself as this sort of
centerpiece of a society in which human
desire and human want and human anxiety
would all be responded to and would be
all be met purely through the free
enterprise system
but in reality the world's fair have
been an elaborate piece of propaganda
designed by bernie sanders goldberg's
eyes privately bernays did not believe
that true democracy could have a word
freight training
believed that this meant it was too
dangerous to let the masses ever have
control over their own lives
those platelets and consumers was a way
of giving people the illusion of control
while allowing a responsible elite
to continue managing society
so if you have all your desires met and
yeah you're that's what you want hey get
this red car you're going to be super
cool bro hey get this new dress get the
new iphone right
my phone get your obama phone the
government
don't play
[Laughter]
all right whatever you get to buy new
shirts that's not that bad
all right what about when it actually
comes to foreign relationships
like taking over a country for good
reasons but you're still uh
you know taking over a country for a
good cause so this is my favorite clip
because i actually agree with him here
but at the end of the day he is still
manipulating the masses and their
perception of reality this is guatemala
for decades united fruit had controlled
the country through pliable dictators
it was known as a banana republic
banana but in 1950 a young officer
colonel arbenz was elected
president he promised to remove united
fruits control over the country so he
was hired by a banana company basically
under to take over trying to transform
this and brilliantly did transform it
into an issue of a communist threat i
thought i smelled a big
the cia trained and armed a rebel army
as planes flown by cia pilots dropped
bombs on guatemala city edward bernays
he was preparing the american population
to see this as the liberation of
guatemala by freedom fighters for
democracy who would happen when
conditions in the public and the press
allowed for a coup to happen and he
created those conditions
opinion in a way that's undemocratic and
manipulative well what i love about is
that hey i agree with him you had to
take over guatemala but it was hilarious
that was because a banana company paid
him to do so yeah wow that's amazing
okay but look it's guatemala so i don't
know here i
i love how you just set me up perfectly
i swear i didn't mean that right hey
what do you care about guatemala oh i
don't even have coke like colombia what
do they have no bananas evidently
gonorrhea sure and that the cia gave
them yes ah so whoopsie that's our bad
how is propaganda
fc how does this affect you i have an
overlays called propaganda do you guys
know only six years ago the supreme
court
uh
legalized gay marriage right yes yeah
there you go all right so this is what
happens when you go into netflix yeah
it's not really subliminal anymore
that only exists because bernays created
the system
to do that and when you see it you will
normalize it and it will create your
reality and then fun fact you know the
ceo of netflix yeah it's mark randolph
yes that's not his that's not his full
name it's mark bernice randolph
what yes it is what i'm gonna have to
ask talk to me is there any relation of
course what now
yes he's he was the co-founder of
netflix
yeah he's from the bernie's family
whoa
it's not that shocking thank you for
educating us and uh helping us with the
propaganda of our youth
this has been the truth according to
smoke many
let me take uh let's take if there's one
really good chat to end on because i
know we've gone late and uh you know uh
uh dave has a prostate the size of a
grapefruit i do
okay the doctor says it's eventually
going to take my soul
oh no
all right sarah b he's gotta everybody
wants to know how do we show this
hypocrisy to people who try to stay out
of politics slash the world events so
they understand why they need to be
aware wait how do we show this hypocrisy
to people who stay out of um
you know what that's actually a good
question i will say this you start with
an entry point that is something that
matters to them because politics affects
everything and it really bothers me
we've talked about this like a lot of
christians go oh jesus wasn't political
uh incorrect
so um
politics affects everything in politics
on
and i know a lot of these people
politicians are very different right
politicians often are not the best among
us but politics certainly in the united
states is a reflection of your values
it's a manifestation of your values and
so when someone thinks i'm not
interested in politics okay does your
kid go to school no is your kid
homeschooled
either does your is your kid a part of
the education the educational system
either at home private okay guess what
you're now involved in politics hey do
you pay taxes and oh you're now involved
in politics hey do you own a house
you're now involved in politics hey do
you think that uh you know it's wrong
for you to be rounded up and arrested or
your neighbors rounded up and arrested
for simply owning a fire oh you care
about politics do you believe that you
shouldn't live in fear of being arrested
oh you care about politics what you need
to do is find out the entry point and
this happens a lot um you don't need to
give them the republican or democrat
spiel you find something that touches
somebody's life and what a lot of people
fail to understand
is that your values define who you are
your principles define who you are and
those things define uh how you vote and
we've talked about this in the past look
today you're not really sacrificing you
know rams or sheep right this but this
was a way back then to
physically manifest your faith to
effectively give something physically
something tangible something that could
be quantified um give it away with no
actual promise or expectation of
something return you're doing it in
you're doing it in faith
there really only two ways to do that
today
tithing to your church and then
something that is permanent that you
stamp as a manifestation of what you
believe a dog in the fight with no
promise of somebody is vote
that's what you can do you can tie it to
your church at where you spend your
dollars and you can vote
those and actions are what define you
not what you say
and politics is a manifestation of
action and i know the irony is not lost
on me that you take action and get
active and vote and then you have
politicians who do nothing uh more than
speak however it is a significant action
on your part and it affects every aspect
of your life so you don't need to give
them a political speech you don't need
to you don't need to stump find
something that touches their lives that
you know matters to them and somehow
help them understand
how that's affected by the world around
them and who they vote for where they
spend their dollars
because your actions define you
not this i'm pointing to a mouse you
take your chats
okay julia hey that's a that's a great
voice you got there julia has a question
are character people impressions
something you have to practice a lot
before you're comfortable doing them is
it difficult to get the voices right do
you have a favorite impression uh i
don't really know that i get them right
you get pretty close
your jack black is yeah
it's very good you don't look very good
the impression is you just have to take
the words put them in the back of your
mouth oh
put the words in your mouth
that's it exactly so i i don't mean to
like sometimes i just do them because my
my
dad just put that on the [ __ ] mask
please
i'm sorry i can't look at him he keeps
him staying in character putting on the
mask do you want the basketball like
it's different like when you're there
and you're dressing up it's just easier
to look at when i'm just looking and
you're like dejected i feel like you
pinched for me because dave landau had
to go to a funeral when you put the mask
on it seems like you're enjoying it
what are you wearing
what's the matter with you um i don't
want to show my that's my tuck yeah no
but my my dad i always used to do voices
as a kid and a lot of times it's sort of
more of a character than a direct
impression yeah um but i will say this
when i would actually have to work on
impressions like ones that i hadn't done
if we were doing some like like a sketch
parody or something like like matthew
mcconaughey or a daniel day lewis um was
one that i had to do that were or rob
robin williams was one that i'd never
done until we did the goodwill hunting
yeah um parody and that was you know you
know something will
i don't think you're silly
you're just some grown-up kid you know
that was this yeah yeah hey will let's
talk about it hey oh oh it will it's
just one of those things where i had to
listen almost like i know this is going
to sound silly remember mission
impossible yeah when they were uh
putting on like all of the voices the
voice stuff and it says say this phrase
so this is what i would do when it was
an impression i would have to work on i
would try and pick one of the most
iconic scenes of an actor and i would
just repeat the actual lines from that
scene because i knew that i could get it
down as an impression yeah and then i
would try and say
uh some phrases that i knew included
kind of all vowels and all of the sort
of the the the plosives that you needed
you know because these are the things
where you often sort of determine
someone's twang um and then what i would
do is i would just not look in the
mirror and try and make myself make it
their face yeah you know so whether it's
like charles bronson or whether it's
like joe i've done josh hartnett i just
think of the face think of the face and
then start doing and then eventually
kind of look in the mirror yeah and get
close enough and there are some that are
going to be out of your register that's
just true there are just some that you
won't be able to do does making the face
help the voice or does it just kind of
help you get into the character it kind
of well because when you're doing it you
want to be
you want to include all of it as best
you can so it's not necessarily to help
and it doesn't necessarily hurt
sometimes it's kind of tough like the
charles bronson thing sometimes makes it
harder to the voice because of the way
you have to stretch your neck you know
with the like
yeah that was difficult for you that day
because it was like you you
hey you
crazy puke
but slingblade
helps you with the voice doesn't it
slingblade helps you with the voice when
you do it when you kind of do the i
don't know it's been a long time but the
thing with the thing with the
thing with the sling blade is uh
you got to give them autistic eyes which
is not meant to be an insult but what it
is is there's no depth of focus and uh
let's see i'm not actually a lot of
people just go they just go out and go
like this and they go huh no the key is
look with the eyes this is something
actually having worked with special
needs people um it is something that's
very common it's a lack of ability to
focus yeah and so a lot of people wonder
what it is about the eyes that are
different and what it is is typically
like for example you see me if i look at
if i look at my dad you you can see a
shift in focus in the eyes right yeah
and so with the slingblade thing the
hardest thing to get and i notice people
just go look i'm doing my chin and going
but what you have to do is kind of stop
and see it doesn't matter where i look
you don't really see any change in the
way my eyes go whether i'm looking at
you with the camera or just looking
right here at the microphone
it's all about the same distance for
that
and you have to notice some things
usually someone have something unique
like their eyes or sometimes they'll
have a way they pronounce their s's like
jenner
but i repeat myself yeah that's what i
would say is first just listen to them
by osmosis then just the firs the
easiest thing to do is just impersonate
those exact lines and try and pick up on
some subtleties then you can turn into
characters like dana carvey none of his
impressions sound like the person but
yeah well it's close enough but they're
really funny exactly yeah yeah and i
think you do a good job of like taking
like tidbits and like throwing them in
at the right time anytime you do jack
black he lights up i literally every
time you do it i look really quickly he
just like smiles as big as possible and
every time you say the word chat i just
imagine christopher walken saying it
don't even always say it like him but i
just think it works i can never work him
in and stand up and then it's kind of
the way i talk if i'm talking with you
in in real life i just if i'm talking
about someone else or just i usually
just end up doing it exactly voluntarily
but it feels very natural it's not like
you're just trying to do something
you're just talking and then you'd go
into it like trump a lot of times you
start talking and then you're like
excuse me yeah you just like go into it
there's a great example if i were to do
an accurate trump okay yeah an accurate
trump is not as funny uh kind of like
the bernie is not the bernie one
but if you really look if you're not
going cartoonish with donald trump it's
not really as severe as people when
they're giving a speech folks
that sounds more like actual right that
sounds more like actual donald trump but
then you turn it up a little bit nasally
and make it a little more cartoonish
because it's more fun to do you like it
it has to start from accurate and then
you kind of tweak because you're trying
to bring out certain personalities it's
hilarious though you're bernie i don't
even care that you know like it doesn't
sound the godfrey bernie but both both
impressions are good though they're very
bernie and the god-free but they work
together as one kid they're very silly
it's so funny oh you're very good we got
invited so much we got so much hate when
i hosted the show
when bernie sanders hosted the show what
they didn't see is like before even i
don't know we didn't show that tape like
before so you come in and you're like
you tell us you're like all right i'm
going to be in character the entire time
so like don't do anything to take me out
of character always address me as bernie
sanders and so you come in and you're
kind of moping in and we're having
technical difficulties yeah we're like
going through some stuff
and then and then you started actually
criticizing us as bernie sanders really
it's not me
you're like well just i thought you guys
had your game together and uh
i don't remember that at all
yeah let me know i will say this
together
yes
i will say this though speaking of uh
you know like debates uh that happened
this week the schuyler turden thing with
the devil's advocate uh
i kind of developed a little two things
a little bit of a reputation but first
off
people i would tell them you're not
going to be talking with me it's going
to be skyler turton and and then i would
say just so you know and this is
something too that i've always we have
no you you booked the show you know we
have never lied to anybody as far as no
our point of view i always say let them
know that i disagree with them
because i don't want to send back them
because i see it's just when people do
it right of course so i always say look
if we bring on someone whether they're
from salon from new york times we have
to be honest about it and i do the same
thing with devil's advocate whether it's
jordan peterson whether it's john sasse
or whether it's whether it's even people
who are friends i go look look just so
you know this isn't going to be like one
of those conservative webcam videos oh
why are liberals always like hey i'm
patriotic but they hate america i said
i'm going to try and present the most
convincing arguments that i can from the
left yeah um and they're like yeah okay
but then afterwards i won't say who but
there's three people who said i
i didn't expect that yeah
and you kind of tripped me up a little
bit yeah um and it became harder to get
conservatives to do it so it's not
actually people that wouldn't be able to
like play along it's like come on you've
been there's some of that too this is a
character and they're like oh oh i see
what you're doing there and it's like no
don't you're not supposed to say it like
yeah you're supposed to be debating
somebody who has a different opinion
yeah there's the old was the old saying
preparation beats perspiration that's
kind of how i treat you but it goes i
would say it's preparation beats
perspiration then perspiration i guess
beats sort of self-adulation like people
who love to go out there it's like i'm
the best i'm great no no no no prepare
then work really hard yeah and expect to
get your ass kicked yeah work like
somebody else out there can beat you
right yeah and so i would always deal
with devil's advocate but usually taken
from the counter arguments for debates
that we've done in the past or or
potential points that people might
present and change my minds
and uh
it trips some people up sometimes well
it helps you prepare too because you're
actually trying it's kind of like if you
want to really know a subject make sure
that you can teach it like give have the
ability to teach to somebody else you
have to go through all the intricacies
of it if you have to make the argument
yourself and hear a rebuttal and then
have something to say on top of that
you've really kind of dove deep and
that's why i always teach kids that
american history started in
16
16 19 16 19. absolutely it's a great
project all right let's take another
chat let's take two more and then we'll
call this uh a day because i'm sure that
uh
pop's crowders
oh yeah
they're trying to get a lot of catch a
glimpse on the monitor it's just i'm
reminded it's horrible okay hope hope
has a question for gerald what's a good
organic wine to buy i love wine but
refuse to buy california wines due to
the pesticides used that's not really
accurate though there's a lot of isn't
mostly organic wine
like if anybody comes in and sells their
wine to me is this is organic and this
is all the state fruit and that's the
only i'm like yes but your wine sucks
you have no one to blame but yourself
it's all your fruit can't even point the
finger at anybody else that's a really
bad argument but channel the smelt
i don't care they can't i can't
[Laughter]
it's got to be like a boot camp for them
if you can't get past this point you
don't deserve to listen can you imagine
trying to argue
to
tin of smelt he's like yeah
and then he smacks it and it goes back
into the water
you don't know where to keep from the
cpr in the smell get the paddles
that's insane i love it
it is a little bit of bs though look
grapes are mostly organic in napa valley
if you're buying really crappy
mass-produced wine and they do use a lot
of chemicals to kind of take care of
that process yeah do stuff and if you're
buying nicer wines
from from napa and sonoma other places
around there's tons of places in
california on the west coast that do a
great job with this but most of the time
farmers are smart they try to do
something sustainable right and
sustainable tends to be more organic
naturally they're not out there for the
most part trying to just pitch oh i'm
organic bro they're like actually this
makes a consistent product that people
will buy after a year and that's the
market dictating the terms of the
engagement there not some politicians
saying you can't use a chemical okay
well fine sometimes you have to use this
right i know you're exactly right to
make sure that you don't lose an entire
crop to an invasive species i did a
segment a long time ago before i had
started this so this might have been in
2012
2013 where i went to a goat farm and
just because i was
i think i was maybe even working at fox
news but i used to
pay for my own stuff and then they run
it on it oh yeah so it was a goat from i
was trying to compare this actual like
goat farm where these people clear like
the goats were outside you could see
them roaming in the grass but they
weren't certified organic because they
had to use some kind of a
i don't know if it's curing or a lacquer
on their wooden fence post too oh yeah
you know
and then this huge clearly factory hog
farm right across the road was certified
organic yeah um and this happens a lot
too there's there's one cigar that i
believe was certified organic and i had
to lose the label uh from a company
called um placencia and i think it
doesn't have it anymore and here's the
thing tobacco's really generally
speaking an organic crop now do they use
some pesticide show but nicotine
caffeine these are natural pesticides
too yeah and in a lot of cases they
would be what certainly more organic or
sustainable than what a lot of people
would consider organic that label
doesn't really mean anything no and the
best thing to do with food and pro
probably with wine you correct me from
wrong is
know where it comes from so if you can
know the farm it comes from you know
there are plenty of great wines and
that's the reason i haven't named one
because i could name there's like
thousands of them that do this job
really well and aren't super expensive
either right so just look it up real
quick online
don't just no
[Laughter]
you can pay for that
organic tag too like a friend of mine
his family owned a avocado farm
and i remember we were at a grocery
store
different friend uh we were at a grocery
store and he was like don't ever buy
organic avocados and i was like why not
he was like dude they just pay for that
yeah yeah they pay for it you know
what's crazy about avocados right so the
hipster thing to do in california is
it's been this way for a while to eat
avocado this avocado that avocado toast
you know what the the worst consumer of
water per piece of fruit or per pound of
fruit is aloe vera avocados buy yeah i
know that is that that's why
was stealing water avocado worth it not
worth it these guys are out there like
picketing because of the smelt fish but
then they're eating avocado
the good fat gerald i don't care it's a
super food yeah where are we gonna get
it where are we gonna get the omegas the
smell they can't swim
that should make them easy to catch
they're poor swimmers god give them
floaties
then after greta thundberg say that yeah
oh human beings are so cruel really yeah
if we were so if we were the cruelest
species on a planet it seems we wouldn't
have to be protecting the fish that
can't swim from every other species who
doesn't care yeah exactly all right stop
eating the smell you stupid bastard yeah
seal's just like
what huh
these guys are swimming slowly sorry i
couldn't hear you there's smelt coming
out of my ears
i don't know but it will make a good
imax film
gerald
all right final chat
okay final chat comes from aaron blanson
question what was the biggest content
related challenge when the show was just
beginning
ooh um
is this back in the once a week days
yeah it depends on what you mean in the
world every day like we went daily that
was a big trend yeah that was hashtag
never dated
um
well okay i will say this when it was uh
weekly
uh it was all the commercial breaks when
it was on radio yeah so you had to you
would have like i think
i think it's like 16 minutes of
commercial breaks and so in one show we
would have like 12 michael jackson song
yeah we have like 12 captain planet
sketches 12 white privileged boys we
have so many of these things so that was
really tough um
what else was really tough was uh
figuring out at that point this was sort
of pre everyone doing this it was either
you did audio podcasts or you did short
videos yeah like figuring out how to get
a switcher that worked all that kind of
stuff building a set where you could see
us
and also since we had to go to radio
terrestrially making sure that we had a
system that we could do that would go to
radio but also not have lag and go
online right yeah and i tell you what
this is the truth when we initially
started um
i just said like okay this is you know i
own the rights of this podcast and it
was just going up on itunes and i was on
reading you know syndicated to you know
more markets than than you know a show
that's i think we were like in 12 maybe
we were 16 markets yeah um which doesn't
really mean a whole lot to the am radio
thing it's a lot of radio is a sham just
be clear just because you're in that
market it doesn't mean that you have
listeners in that market depends on the
time and depends on the station the
market so anyway but um i always
maintain the rights and so i plan to do
it online at this point there really
were no video podcasts on youtube yeah
um it's really not anything prominent
and so i said well we're gonna run the
first one to see what happens and at
this point it's like a three hour show
and i was like ooh like uh you know 12
000 plays
well maybe this isn't something maybe
you know what maybe it's just one of
those things we always play i always
plan to start mug clubs like maybe this
is one of the things that super fans
will pay for yeah and we can give them
this additional video content but you
know uploaded it for a while and then by
the second month it was like oh okay you
know
45 000.
which is better than a lot of even
podcasts on youtube right now when you
were doing the videos prior to this yeah
short video in the shorter videos and
then it was a few months and oh over a
hundred thousand right and then you know
once you crack that that uh quarter
million mark you know then you have
spawn then you have a bunch of sponsors
that i say no to
um and so we i didn't know that it was
going to work because you have to
remember at that time so this is what i
would say was most of it let me give you
a macro what's been most difficult in my
life okay at that time everyone said
short short short short short
youtube is short yeah how are you going
to compete with the turtle humping a
work boot how are you going to compete
with the guy breaking his arm on a
skateboard right they would say short
short short short short that's what you
have to do and i remember even at fox
news trying to tell them um how things
sort of worked online and and i didn't
believe that you had to be so short
because even my short videos would be
three sometimes seven minutes and i was
doing these packages i said look if
there's buy-in people will stay with you
yeah you just have to make sure that you
set it up at the beginning so they know
what the context is
um and when i was at fox news for
example they would remove my own
appearance appearances on fox news on my
youtube channel i'd ask them beforehand
yeah and they're like well we just don't
want it because then why would people
tune into fox news and at this point i
was like look it's 80 000 people it's
most of these people are 20 year olds
they're not watching
head on roll on headache free they're
not buying gold and wilford brimley's
diabetes prick yeah um stick whatever it
is the thing the sticker um so they
would remove it and then the same thing
when i would talk with with radio people
they're going we want you to do this
radio is all local like well this is
actually
some of this is kind of changing a
little bit yeah and then i even had
people who would bring me in to work
with other i would say sort of like
click bait conservative sites saying
like well opinion doesn't do well
original content doesn't do well and say
uh i think you're kind of lying because
i know you what you don't understand is
you're copying someone's original
content for example courtney had had
some columns that have been ripped off
many many times so i constantly had to
retrain people good example here two
ads
this is the first show that i know of
not only that did com that has done
commercials like we've done yeah but uh
token allen knows and gerald knows and
uh my dad certainly knows this we had
sponsors early on drop out because they
would say we want you to do a live read
before the beginning of the show and i
would say well i don't first off i don't
do live reads um we do these clever
commercials and at least we like to
think that we package them in a way
that's more clever than just hey buy
this use a discount code for you know
tick medicine whatever
and so remember i used to tell them i
would say look look we're going to put a
commercial we're going to keep it very
limited we only do one i think we've
done the most we've ever done is two
commercials in a single show
uh sponsor placements really yeah so
we're going to put it in the middle of
the show because first off you put ads
at the beginning of a show people just
skip i know i do that
30 seconds skip 30 seconds and when we
work it into the program as a sketch as
something where we actually put some
work into it we notice that people
re-upload our sketches yeah and they get
a lot of plays and we're going to do
that with
you as a sponsor and they would say no
no our market research tells us that uh
that we want uh live read first 30
seconds and they wouldn't pay a dime for
youtube because again podcast didn't
exist on youtube remember so they don't
want to include it only why because it
was automatic downloads
well how many automatic downloads do you
have on your phone right now does that
mean that you're listening to it and are
you listening to the first one minute
well guess what the standard is now now
we have advertising agencies going to
other shows saying we don't excluding
you can't put the ad in the first minute
yeah
but i had to fight upstream all the time
and that's why we ended up going with
sponsors directly because a lot of the
advertising firms just didn't understand
i was like look i don't have time to and
you know what hopefully you guys let me
know you can chat chat with us hopefully
we've made a better show for you i've
always said not if it hurts the show i
don't want people to feel bogged down
with two and a half minutes of boring
live reads and i'm not going to dave's
built bar yesterday was fantastic
integrated into the show right you know
what and i'm not going to lie about a
product either because some of them are
like you need to get big and strong
it's a joke the truth is you don't need
protein bars but some people out there
need to fit in some extra protein if
you're an athlete and most of them suck
the only reason that i eat built bars is
because they taste like candy bars
otherwise i wouldn't eat them i just eat
candy bars
but think about how prophetic that was
here we are almost six years later
you're doing white privilege boys and
where are we today right yeah not even a
term
yeah i mean it wasn't really a term not
not as it's not the colloquialism that's
been become known as today so i would
say the biggest fight first off is um
obviously the big tech issue that's
always been the biggest fight right it's
always been the biggest fight and it
cost me a lot in legal fees and then the
second biggest fight because it's not
just people in the industry who are left
but also people in our own industries
people on the right who also can't be
bothered to
try and go where the puck is going to be
as opposed to where the puck is and uh
it's been really exhausting to try and
educate people nope
i'll just go through a list nope videos
don't have to be 30 seconds or less on
youtube yeah no podcasts are actually
going to be a really big thing podcasts
are in video form are actually going to
be a big thing no we don't want to put
advertising at the beginning of uh the
show we want to integrate them uh with
the with the live audience oh and a
recent one too doing the show live
yeah yeah doing the show live how many
people have said don't do the show live
mm-hmm how many professionals have said
don't have a show like you can go watch
an interview with david letterman where
he was talking about before he did his
show at night uh he had a morning show
yeah and he was asked about it i think
it was charlie rose and he said well
look we were doing a we were doing an
hour and a half show live
from uh from 10 to 11 30 said it was
suicide no one could do it
that was what david letterman said he
said doing it live was just crazy and of
course we're doing it live now not with
the fcc but people aching to hit the
band button so that's the most recent
one people said no no live doesn't work
live doesn't work live doesn't work and
that's another thing because the
industry would say well if you do it
live then it goes to archive and you
don't get a notification right so this
we used to do this a long time ago we
would stream it live and then sometimes
we'd have to delete it and re-upload it
and then we said you know what i think
that people now remember having this
conversation i think that people now
actually want that sort of live
experience because now everything is a
la carte and so it's sort of coming full
circle it really is we let people know
that we're live and we prove that's a
big part of why we have cnn so you can
prove you know nothing but must leave
that it's live i think it'll mean
something to people because they're
experiencing it authentically alongside
us in the morning and everyone said no
way you're taking you're taking your
life in your hands anything can go wrong
live and it won't work and people don't
watch live anyway well i think you're
wrong yeah one of the big things you did
really well people didn't figure out was
the free stuff and how important the
free content was oh well yeah that's to
make everything work you know free
lunches kid and all that that lecture
you got at fox i don't know is fox
nation free
like it is now isn't it i don't know
maybe but no i think what you're saying
is if people had their way everything
would be behind the people yeah exactly
yeah they didn't want anything going on
youtube they saw it as competition and i
was saying you have to see it as
complementary and these are just things
that have been a really uphill uh
struggle that that's what i would say
i'm proud of
what our whole team has done and that we
at the very least if nothing else i
think it's been pretty clear that we've
we've been uh ahead of the eight ball
and at least had a vision as to what we
want to do with this company and you
know right now that's uh fighting back
and and being live and and being
authentic and making sure that we're
honest um while hopefully not being
removed but you know nothing to walk on
but land mines yeah nothing to walk on
what are we about to say there gerald i
i was going to say something about um
the uh the ad thing gosh oh the ad thing
oh so no not the ad saying sorry you
said you were ahead of the game with the
the live thing and people want something
that they can actually just go and kind
of be in and not have to select yeah
it's absolutely right if you look at any
of the online platforms right now like
hbo or amazon what you're starting to
see is actually all of the videos but
also like a live section right so you
can just go on you know hbo if you've
got a subscription going on oh what's
playing on hbo right now and so many
people are putting their interest in
that because they don't want to go
through like how many times do you
scroll through all these different
movies and you can choose any of them
that you want you have like this
embarrassment of movies to choose from
and you're like no no no but then you
see live you don't have to think about
it you just click it it's on you're good
to go think about it not even like that
but
you don't have to ponder it i'll use
different words
right and you just click it so you're
right like you've you've been ahead in a
lot of ways well you know what else too
i will a lot of people don't understand
this
i keep hearing the door open
oh that's your cufflink jack okay it's
because i have shorts i thought we were
under attack i was reaching for the
walter button so um
this actually is really
the first show of this of this
proportion what i mean a show that gets
and and i'll talk about this but i try
to avoid this uh just in
public no millions of people right
millions of people on on each show
full-length show not clips millions of
people
um
that when you think about it actually is
a full-scale production television show
that is live so what you have is live
radio which is someone talking into a
microphone sure and then shows like
trevor noah like colbert those shows
aren't live at all tokunawa knows this
they're taped in the afternoon this
actually is i've now every now and then
we have to pre-tape a guest or or
something like that because you know
what i mean or like you know what was
supposed to be a scheduled debate
uh because people you know need to be
accommodated but in general this is this
is a live show and you also still have
clips and you still have sketches yeah
and you have
writing and preparation they're really
johnny carson wasn't live david
letterman wasn't live and jay leno
wasn't live uh and then you have a lot
of these morning shows that aren't
live and then some of them are but
they're they're not doing what what we
do you know the view isn't putting on a
built bar sketch yeah no um
jimmy kimmel has live in the name and
it's taped at like 3pm yeah well but
here's the thing about live people don't
realize this like when we switched over
from uh you know or went to kind of this
live show at this length yeah i would
get out of here and just be like
exhausted because the entire time you
are there is no cut there is no like hey
let's take that from the top again hey
let's let's i forgot the fact that i was
about to quote can we can we go back and
insert something right there is none of
that you just have to be on and to give
you an idea two hours people like well
am radio um
let me give an example someone who's one
of the best to have ever done rush
limbaugh yeah rush limbaugh never had to
go more than 20 minutes without at least
a five minute break
yeah
wow if you look at the radio yeah now
that makes sense what's what are the
radio brakes there uh they're the short
break is i want to say five minutes and
we would have some seven eight minute
breaks on the hour you know and it was
about 16 minutes of commercials in any
given
and that's not just it doesn't matter
how big your audience is because local
businesses have to run those commercials
yeah so i'll tell you this doing two
hours like this
um
is way more difficult than when i would
it's exhausting on radio it's far far
more confident if you're doing three
hours on am radio you're actually doing
about an hour 20. yeah
with a lot of breaks but we love doing
it because we had these conversations
that were just so much fun me you and
dave and your dad and quarterback
everybody in this room and we're like
how do you capture that kind of energy
yeah how do you capture that kind of fun
kind of just sitting around listening to
us talking sometimes you may be like
whatever he's talking about sports oh
it's soccer who cares right but then
another time a random joke comes up that
if it was a program that was scheduled
and and pre-recorded would probably
never have come up no right this
hilarious moment happens just naturally
and you love it it's yeah it's it's a
lot of fun and also learning happens on
air i didn't know that much i didn't
here's the thing i knew about the smell
i just knew that they truly did not know
that they took a whole segment they were
they're poor swimmers and we need to
accommodate them a lot of these guys
today steven doing radio aren't they
isn't their podcast
just the same thing really they're all
that's right the audio podcast is the
radio show yeah yeah just packaged
differently look there's nothing there's
nothing wrong with that not at all of
course
it's just not what we do the amount of
preparation is is very different um and
it's it's been uh look it's been a lot
of work to to try and be ahead of the
curve and to try and make sure that we
can still have these conversations with
you and i will say it's it's a pretty
cool community um yeah i honestly don't
get to have as much touch with you as
some of the other folks here because uh
i just don't have as much time and so i
don't get to so that's why i really
don't get myself that's kind of nice
yeah
yeah i hate airports hey the costumes
are great but quarter black this this
environment you created here nice studio
is pretty good very nice it is
tremendous and it's hellscape like
resemblance to california
well that's been cultural appropriation
month again stay tuned set your
notifications on youtube if you're on
the blaze here too because there will be
a lot of long-form content going up here
this month of july but the show will not
be live we'll be back the first week of
august with my new well not ticker rib
cage
for my ticket
i'll see you
hey if you like this video hit that
notification bell
up there uh or subscribe or share this
right isn't that right dave smash that
like button and share it where'd you
wear it what are you wearing there
that's nice oh this is uh i found it in
the trash yeah also known as
your shirt
crowdershop.com which is where you can
go and support and uh
we
we have overs we keep the overstock in
the trash
it's for people who are little yeah he
says i haven't earned it yet because i
ain't grown all the way by the way if
you find hunter biden's gun in there
just let it be